we've already shown off a multitude of
mechanics and concepts that The Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild never
explains outright yet there's so much
more we're finding out about the game
even beyond the 50 hour mark with so
many secrets still hidden in its
mysterious world we've compiled eight
more useful things to know to help you
on your journey
be wary there are potential spoilers
ahead if you enjoy this video like it
and subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more features on breath of the wild and
be sure to watch our previous videos on
all the things I wish I knew before I
started
if you find a dog in any of the towns or
stables don't just crouch down and
nuzzle it feed the pup three pieces of
meat or fruit to show it you care after
doing so it'll lead you to a treasure
chest hidden in the surrounding area for
example if you feed the dog oh and a hat
eh no village it takes you to a chest
containing a silver rupee make sure to
feed all the pups in Hyrule to acquire
all sorts of secret treasure
like in past Zelda games if you use
excessive force against cuoco it'll call
upon a swarm of its friends to attack
you while triggering a cuoco swarm isn't
in your best interest it's possible to
make it work in your favor
simply grab a cocoa and bring it with
you into battle in whichever unfortunate
enemy happens to hit you will be swarmed
and pecked to death it's important to
note that a cocoa swarm only does
minimal damage against higher-level
enemies like guardians and Lionel's so
don't push your luck
[Music]
gardens are a tremendous threat early on
mostly because of their incredibly
destructive laser blasts but if you have
decent reflexes you can actually parry a
Guardians laser blast with your shield
and send it straight back at them to do
so get close to a guardian and wait for
it to charge up a shot when you hear a
beep that's your cue to press a do this
three times to make a standard Guardian
explode though a stationary guardian can
be destroyed with one shot once you've
mastered parry and guardian shots these
once dangerous foes become much less
threatening it's also one of the most
efficient ways to defeat a guardian as
it doesn't require any weapon use nor
doesn't wear down your shields
durability be wary this tactic is
incredibly ineffective against multiple
Guardians as it can only be implemented
while locking onto one of them so once
again don't push your luck
after spending hours traveling across
Hyrule on horseback do you ever find
yourself wishing you could customize the
appearance of your trusty steed while
breath of the wild makes it possible
simply go to the outskirts table which
lies to the north of the great plateau
and west of the Colosseum ruins when you
reach the stable tucked Akane
the lady tending the horses outside she
offers to change out your horse's saddle
or bridle with any new ones you've found
but she also lets you alter the mane of
your horse looking to style your horse's
mane with some sweet french braids or
maybe you'd like to give a long flowing
green mane Connie can make it happen I
personally prefer the mohawk mane for
opponent you hear it's edgy keep in mind
Connie only offers her services to
horses that are raised with lots of love
so if you don't have a max bond with
your horse she'll reject you
have you ever spotted a guardian in the
distance while on horseback and thought
well looks like I'm not going that way
well you'll be surprised to know that
you can actually use your horse to
charge straight through it simply spur
your horse in the direction of an
approaching guardian and watch as it
doubles over the both of you it's worth
noting that if you don't charge through
the Guardian Center base
it might not flinch much from your
charge so be careful in your approach
and make sure to keep spurring your
horse on to maximize your force of
impact this technique can also be used
to repeatedly tear off of a Guardians
legs drastically hindering its movement
you'll often encounter a fair amount of
rusty weapons which while useful at
first eventually become obsolete as you
find stronger weapons to add to your
arsenal
but don't just ignore every rusty weapon
you find make sure to keep a couple in
your inventory for the inevitable moment
you encounter rock octorok in the Death
Mountain region this might seem strange
but try tossing a rusty weapon onto the
ground for the little critter to suck up
after it does so wait a few seconds and
then it'll spit out the weapon in
brand-new condition keep in mind the
weapon it spews out is randomized based
on the web intime for example if you
toss it a rusty broadsword you might get
a traveler sword while another time
you'll get the more powerful royal
broadsword take advantage of this
refurbishment technique to nab some
decently powered weapons
often in you journey you'll work hard to
figure out how to survive some of the
world's more extreme weather conditions
there are a few specialized clothing
options and elixirs that can help keep
your body temperature in check but
there's actually a little-known
alternative elemental weapons elemental
weapons affect your body temperature and
depending on which you choose your body
temperature will either increase or
decrease for example if you're in the
hot arid Gerudo desert equipping an ice
rod or a great frost blade will lower
your body temperature this is a handy
technique to use in your travels as it
lets you keep your stronger armor
equipped while in extreme climates it's
also a great option if you simply lack
the other survival options available to
you
hidden in the outskirts of Hyrule is a
mysterious merchant named kilted to find
this eccentric peddler wait until
nighttime and then head to the left eye
of Skull Lake when you talk to Kelton he
tells you he's going to set up shop at
various villages across the land before
disappearing to do just that to find him
search the outskirts of any of the main
villages and towns between 8 p.m. to 4
a.m.
Hilton shop is relatively easy to
identify it appears as a patchwork hot
air balloon from a distance once you
find him kill tin sells an assortment of
useful and quirky monster related items
such as the much sought-after monster
extract cooking ingredients or a maudlin
mask which allows you to blend in with
Mobley's however you can only purchase
these items using a special currency
known as mam which you can acquire by
trading in monster parts to kill him
make sure to visit Kelton shop often as
he frequently stalks up on a variety of
new and useful items after all you never
know when you might need a back hablen
mask to blend in / party with a pack of
unassuming but complex
what other cool mechanics have you found
let us know in the comments below and
for more coverage on the Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild be sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel
[Music]